jetzt ist es absolut sicher es gibt
wasser eis auf dem mond neue
auswertungen bestätigen direkt funde am
nord- und südpol die absorption von
infrarotlicht zeigt dass es an den polen
unmengen von wassereis gibt wie es
gefunden wurde und was das für die
mondmissionen in zukunft bedeutet klicks
um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
und am ende des videos gibt es noch eine
kleine sensation wir krempeln nämlich
youtube um die entdeckung von wasser auf
dem mond ist eine lange geschichte denn
selbst nachdem die apollo-missionen
gestein von dort mitgebracht hatten
vermutete niemand wasser auf dem mond
oder gar sogar in diesen proben doch
weit gefehlt 2010 wurde das mondgestein
nach jahrzehnten nochmals untersucht und
tatsächlich wurde wasser darin entdeckt
unter dem mikroskop wurden winzige
anschlüsse in vulkanischen glas und
darin in gesteins bildenden uni wien
kristallen gefunden und schon 2009
entdeckte der manager der nasa an bord
der indischen sonde chandrayaan-1 wasser
auf dem mond 600 millionen tonnen sollen
es dort in tiefen kratzern am nordpol
geben demnach dort auf dem grund wo kein
sonnenlicht hinkommt soll es als eis
existieren und im juli 2017 wurden daten
der sonde präsentiert die sogar wasser
im gesamten mond mattl nachwiesen und
zwar in einer ähnlichen konzentration
wie im erdmantel auch hier auf der erde
soll sich noch im erdmantel der von rund
70 kilometern tiefe unter der
erdoberfläche bis zu rund 2900
kilometern tiefe reicht wasser in der
menge der ganzen ozeane befinden
ähnliche mengen werden dann auch auf dem
mond im verhältnis zu seiner größe zu
finden sein
nur wäre es kaum zu gewinnen doch ein
weiteres experiment förderte im wahrsten
sinne des wortes wassereis zutage die
nasa ließ im oktober 2009 den l cross
satelliten auf den mond stürzen
er wirbelte 5 tonnen staub auf und darin
befanden sich sechs prozent gefrorenes
wasser eine nicht unbeachtliche menge
der mond ist also da ja richtig feucht
aber einigermaßen feucht und die ice
vorkommen an nord und südpol denn die
neueren untersuchungen
jetzt auch ähnliche vorkommen am südpol
bestätigt sind dabei am spannendsten und
können am leichtesten für mond missionen
genutzt werden deshalb wurden diese
vorkommen jetzt noch mal analysiert und
für beide regionen bestätigt die
absorption von infrarotlicht der
moleküle am krad an grund entspricht
genau der signatur von wasser
damit ist es jetzt wirklich sicher es
gibt auf dem mond wasser und zwar in
erheblichen mengen das auch in solchen
mengen vorhanden ist dass es für
zukünftige mondmissionen genutzt werden
damit würden mondmissionen viel
einfacher werden statt wasser mit
dorthin zu nehmen könnte es dort
gewonnen werden der effekt geplanten
missionen werden viel billiger weil
weniger wasser und damit auch weniger
treibstoff benötigt wird ein
riesenschritt für die planung künftiger
missionen die esa die europäische
raumfahrtagentur hat ja bereits mit den
planungen begonnen und diese
erkenntnisse werden diese planung
erheblich vereinfacht und auch die
amerikaner wollen wieder zum mond
genauso wie die russen und die chinesen
der wettlauf hat also wieder begonnen
so und jetzt kommt es wir machen clixoom
werbefrei keine rolle mehr
und ihr könnt das na ja fast unmögliche
möglich machen denn ohne euch geht es
nicht immer wenn wir entsprechend viele
kanal mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten
wir die werbung von jeweils einem video
im monat ab bis es vor keinem video mehr
werbung gibt werdet also mitglied hier
unter dem video und bekommt noch
exklusive extra videos exklusive live
streams und noch ein paar weitere
privilegien einfach hier unter dem video
auf mitglied werden klicken
tausend dank an all diejenigen die schon
dabei sind und das möglich machen werden
werbefreies klingt so das wäre doch
wirklich mal der hammer wenn er immer
garantiert über aktuelle videos
informiert werden wollt dann endet mich
übrigens bei whatsapp darum geht ihr die
bei einigen etwas unzuverlässige am boxi
auf youtube und er verpasst kein video
einfach hier draufklicken und hier da
unten geht es weiter mit dafür auch
dortigen menschen sollen auf dem mond
siedeln bis dann bleibt dran